okay so done probis reasoning and
learning hi uh my name is Yu Jang Troy
um I'm a I'm currently an assistant
professor at Arizona State University uh
visiting Simons this semester um so
today I'd like to tell you broadly about
um about my research which is on problem
reasoning and learning for trustworthy
AI so I'll kind of focus on know the the
problem and like what the high level
main idea is um okay so it's it's really
no news at this point that you know with
um Ai and machine Learning Systems being
used really everywhere um many people
have raised concerns about
trustworthiness and and reliability of
of these systems uh so for example you
might care about um how how fair your
you know automated decision systems um
decision- making systems are can we
explain some of those decisions are they
are they robust to um some some noise in
the data or or missingness and so
on so the first thing I want to note
here is um that these are really
interconnected problems that that we um
that we shouldn't study in isolation so
for example if you um Identify some some
problems with you know bias um in your
machine learning model you might care
about actually getting some explanations
about the behavior to try and debug it
um or if you want to provide for example
fairness guarantees um you might also
care about providing guarantees that
that's again going to be robust to noise
and data or changing changes in
distributions and so
on so we really want like a single
framework um to to study all of these
issues and in my research I and focus
on um the observation that a lot of
these questions can can be formulated as
problemistic inference
tasks so we're going to use the language
of probabilities to to um write all of
all of these um questions down to propic
inference and and um learning problems
and and then uh kind attack them within
the same same
framework so we here we have these um
know probab of queries so Computing you
know probabilities and expectations you
might say Okay um we we like data can I
can I estimate these values from from
data so for for example if you are um
interested in you know how how fair your
predictor is how um if your predictor is
you know equally accurate across
different gender groups which is
actually one of the the more you know
prominent Notions of of fairness um for
classification people have looked at
looked at so in this case um you might
say okay I'm I'm just going to see look
at all the labels um see what my
predictor outputs see how how um
accurate it is for different gender
groups well in practice um the picture
is not not that pretty um we may have
different sources of uncertainties like
biased uh or noise noisy labels you
might have know missing data and so on
that that actually makes it
not so straightforward to to straight um
just estimate from from
data so um so in in in my research um
the the view is to actually um use a
processing model to capture this uh
underlying distribution you know
handling different sources of
uncertainty and then use that model um
as kind of a a backbone or the the back
uh backend engine um to actually answer
the different uh questions in
trustworthy
AI so for this we we actually need a
couple of um couple of Key Properties so
first is that whatever model we choose
and um this inference engine that that
we want to use to to um
um when use as as a foundation of this
framework um we we need that model to be
able to you know and answer different
queries different propos queries uh
efficiently trably and we also want to
do that um without sacrificing how
expressive these models are basically
with um still maintaining the ability to
capture a lot of interesting
distributions so um in in in my work we
particularly look at um the framework of
models called probalistic circuits so in
this picture on on this side I'm of
interested in developing the the
foundations um of of this prop circuits
so for example when what kind of queries
um can I can I answer exactly and
efficiently um what are the implications
about that about um in terms of the
expressiveness of of these models and
then I'm also interested in in you know
on this side where I'm trying to use
those foundations to for example given
given some machine learning model
provide um guarantees and and reason
about Its Behavior and then again um you
use those guarantees and loop it back to
to um actually enforce them during
learning so so that was the the high LEL
picture um if any of these interest
interest you uh I'm happy to chat about
them um throughout the day and also um
at the reception today all right um so
that's it thank
[Music]
you one question yes yes so do you have
any thoughts on the how if your model is
the language model what is the
probabilistic mod in par model play here
um talk about given model being language
model right um so um so far most of the
in terms of the exact results looking
through some the most like simp like
classical models and then um we have
some approximate difference um for going
on recently for um langage models and
and gerp models we're also looking into
actually um reing about proves in terms
of like a l speace of of um models
rather than directly the like input
space so we have some some ongoing work
I'll I'll
Bas I see that there are more questions
but maybe we can ask those on the break
some time so thanks
[Applause]
again